[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
free agency is rolling and so are we
here at draft crash course live in the
bleacher report app i'm the lead nfl
draft analyst here at vr connor rogers
and with me as always every 1pm on
thursdays from stadium stadiums college
football analyst michael felder belder
we have had quarterback news galore
we've had big ticket signings big ticket
trades
how are we feeling how are we living
right now man
busy busy busy man this is one of those
things where you can write a show on
wednesday and then throw it out on
thursday because the landscape keeps
changing but we we change with it we
adapt you know it's all about adaptive
survival that's what we're about to do
especially as this is the nfl's version
of what march madness
it is insane right now and we are going
to look at how all of these big moves in
free agency will affect the nfl draft we
are going to break down the afc west
today which is an absolute shootout
right now with every move going on in
there a new face in russell wilson
taking over the broncos and we're going
to preview the offensive line if that
wasn't enough we're going to go through
the entire offensive line class in four
different tiers for the 2022 nfl draft
but let's start with the obvious
speaking of adapt and survive felder
this guy wants to play football forever
tom brady is back tom brady said i'm
sick of being at home for two months i'd
rather be on a football field
oh man this changed everything felder i
mean the bucks were able to bring back
ryan jensen their center they were able
to bring back carlton davis their top
corner uh tom brady made a phone call to
falcon former falcons wide receiver
russell gage and said get on out of
there come to tampa and win a ring so
the bucks are back to contending they
were essentially in the tank almost
whether it was kyle trask or blaine
gabbert brady is back and felder so are
the bucks
yeah the bucks are back they're back in
business everybody's happy i mean tampa
couldn't be a happier place right now
they are contenders i think that's one
of the ways we always slot these nfl
teams right are you they're really only
they feel like there's three tiers
there's
legitimate contenders ever that you know
they're going to be in the position and
usually that means you have a
quarterback that you like there's no
quarterback that anyone likes more than
tom brady and he's back and then you
have these teams that are kind of in the
middle where they're okay with their
quarterback it's okay and then you have
teams that are in full rebuild mode so
for the bucks they go from literally by
having him come back and then the
signings that that uh followed that they
go from rebuild mode to
contender and we'll see how that shakes
out i want to ask you about baker
mayfield because my man
in his feelings man carl thomas over
here he's emotional
and it's interesting to to to pair that
with what's going on with the sean
watson because i know you said the
browns they're not even in the desean
watson running anymore
no they're not this is moving quickly
and for everybody watching the show it
is now down to the falcons the saints
and the panthers for desean watson the
browns tried and the browns failed and
in doing that they made a not so great
situation much much worse because you
said it felder in his feelings right now
baker mayfield essentially writing a
goodbye to the cleveland fans as you see
right here is this the notes app filter
my goodness man he didn't even go to the
photoshop format he had to get this off
his chest instantly uh via iphone so
baker mayfield seems to want to move on
the browns
we'll see what they do now that they
didn't get watson they are in a brutal
situation with friction with their
franchise quarterback so now it's wide
open here the browns maybe they call up
and try to get jimmy g that's not an
upgrade over a healthy baker mayfield
they are picking 13th although them
selecting a quarterback in this draft
would surprise me that would have to uh
things would really have to fall apart
there felder so when you look at the
baker situation not just how it impacts
cleveland direct directly but how does
it impact what's left of this insane
quarterback market going on in the nfl
obviously we're going to see the price
for quarterbacks in the draft start
start to bubble up right you're gonna
have to pay a little more you're gonna
have to pay the cost to be the boss if
you will and i think the interesting
part's gonna be what happens again you
mentioned the panthers you mentioned the
falcons we we talked about the saints
and ultimately this all boils down to
sean watson right and deshawn watson is
a guy that we know has off the field and
not indicted doesn't mean innocent so
there's off the field issues that you're
going to have to absorb that come with
you trading for him what about the on
the field or on the team issues that
you're going to have to absorb or or the
the the cost if you will that you're
going to have to pay to get him on your
team connor
yeah the price is going to be insane
there's no you know there's no light
cost here even with a pending suspension
that is very likely for desean watson we
could be looking at six plus games uh
can grow to eight it can grow beyond
that for watson especially with the nfl
doing their own investigation like you
said felder there are over 20 civil
cases that have not been settled this is
far from over but his landing spot
that's not deterring teams and the
texans asking price as far as we know is
three first round picks maybe a day two
asset in there somewhere and starting
nfl caliber players and we're not
talking about the 53rd man on the roster
you're hearing names thrown around like
brian burns from the panthers could be
in the mix here we're cesaro ruiz from
the saints there are big time kind of
players involved so this is going to be
a blockbuster and the most important
thing especially for our sake of this
draft focus show felder is if the
falcons don't get them what are they
doing at eight are they running it back
with matt ryan and taking the top
receiver if the panthers don't get him
are they taking a quarterback at six is
that malik willis territory uh because
matt rule is running out of time let's
call it what it is sam darnold a massive
failure of a trade acquisition yeah time
is ticking that's exactly right before
you're showing the door and then the
saints at 18 who are a little bit more
of a unique spot that if they miss here
they're going to be given a little bit
more time to figure this out but at the
end of the day uh the demand is through
the roof right now and as always there
are going to be multiple losers in this
situation
yeah and i i think losers is an
interesting way to describe it because
you might miss out on what but here's
the thing what if the pace the panthers
do miss out on watson but they end up
with malik wilson he becomes a star that
might be a blessing in disguise
and so that's all there are so many
moving pieces here but i do love the way
that it impacts the drought all of this
impacts the draft so
all of those like when you talk about a
mock draft where you talk about player
rankings
once we get into free agency once we get
into the trades all those things impact
what your big board looks like and what
you're going after because we've seen
teams fix needs conor let's hit the
comments and then we can get into kind
of that draft order to talk about that
first round
yeah let's do it all right let's power
through here and speaking of power
through shout out to our power users
power user the first one i have here
mcat 93 always watching the show always
interacting we appreciate you mcat 93
and he had to throw in uh shaking my you
know what head tom brady just retired
already i feel you man i grew up in new
york uh we didn't grow up big time tom
brady fans around here all right from
bloodstorm jet's doing okay are we a
real football team again stick around
because we are not going to talk about
just the new york jets very shortly
we're going to talk about all the big
time free agency players especially the
ones picking at the top of the draft and
how they got better and how they can get
even better from their rookie draft
selections all right eagles webster says
welcome back goat still don't like
playing your team but all respect and
respect you eagles webster and then
mkent93 throws one in here that is very
relevant to today's show any offensive
line you would trade up for in the late
first round you're going to want to
stick around as well because we don't
want to spoil what we have in store for
you with this offensive line class so
let's take a look at the draft order
right now and talk about some of these
big time spenders and felder to be
honest with you we don't have to look
very far the jacksonville jaguars at the
top they invested in offensive line they
franchise tagged cam robinson they paid
brandon sherff a ton of money they paid
christian kirk and zay jones a ton of
money to come play wide receiver for
them yes they did make moves on the
defensive side of the ball but felder
looking at all of these dollars spent on
the offense doesn't it start to feel
like they're opening the door to take
aiden hutchinson number one overall
yeah i mean look they they went out and
they got trevor lawrence some weapons
right that's what he needed he needed
some more guys to throw the football too
you get zay jones who i liked him coming
out of ecu i want to see him fully
actualized we'll see if that can happen
christian kirk obviously we know what
he's been able to do at the next level
really really good football player he's
been good his whole life i think he's
going to continue to be good um you
throw in evan ingram who up and down up
and down we'll see what he's able to do
there but he's another weapon especially
and we'll talk tight ends a little bit
later but i think it's an interesting
prospect i think with the jags yeah i
mean this is it certainly feels like
defense
aiden hutchinson versus kvon thibodeaux
is an interesting discussion for me i
just got done watching both of them
again so which was what is this the
fourth or fifth time we've all done it
it's just
it's it's one of those things where it's
like neither one of them are like are
chase young but
i think pivotal is closer to that
but i also think that hutchinson is
is he he will never be a mistake and i
think that's the real that's the real
discussion here so i think all that
where there's smoke there's fire does
feel like aiden hudson what do you think
i think you nailed it felder i think the
nfl
likes to go with the higher floor
players when they are drafting scared
and i think that is the thibodeau
hutchinson argument in a nutshell i
think right now
when you watch the tape there is a lot
more meat on the bone with kayvon
thibodeaux at the next level where he
can grow into a special talent to me
right now he's in that brian burns tier
which is a really good exciting player
but imagine if he does take that next
jump where he's amongst the elite while
aiden hutchinson he's not nick bosa
let's let's make that clear right that's
a rare kind of a talent is he somewhat
close to joey bosa who was not the same
mover nick was but a special player with
his hands i don't think he's there
either but he's a really really good
player and he's a really good player
right now and i think felder with all
the problems they've had over the years
jacksonville is so scared to miss that
they would rather bet on the higher
floor and hutch
i think you hit the nail on the head
terrified to miss if you miss enough
people just think you're idiots and they
don't want to look like idiots so they
got to pick the guy that's not going to
be a mistake uh let's take it to your
jets connor let's go to your the beloved
jets baby let's go
let's take a look so the jets obviously
picking at four and ten and i think
number four we've talked about this
enough where it's pass rusher uh or a
guy like equanu number 10 became more
interesting because of free agency they
went out they spent on a guard in lake
and tomlinson they went and got a
starting safety in jordan whitehead they
got a corner and dj reed they got two
tight ends with all of that money
allocated there to hopefully improve a
football team that has not had much
success in the last decade now at number
10
it kind of opened the door for a wide
receiver in my eyes felder when you look
at it they didn't get amari cooper
calvin ridley was somebody they were
interested in but obviously that
situation blew up to a place we never
expected it to go the jets are still in
this wide receiver market number 10 the
door is wide open whether it's garrett
wilson drake london
trailing burks jameson williams they
need speed as well i think felder the
good thing about spending besides the
obvious of making your team better it
also gives you a lot more draft
flexibility and now the jets have done
that with the 10th pick
yeah i think it's going to be
interesting to see what they do uh if
you had to pick if you're the j if
you're you're the gm of the jets at ten
i know i know what you're doing it for
you're getting iguano i know that you're
already i know that's for sure you're
getting him if he's there you're taking
him but at 10
which one of these wide receivers do you
think fits into that that team
oh man you know it's interesting if
jamison williams is fully healthy you
just you can't get that speed anywhere
and once again elijah moore is fast but
he's not the same vertical threat that
jameson williams was and they know that
corey davis is not beating anybody over
the top and they know that so
that is a
pending medical situation right if i
needed a high floor player that can run
the route tree that wins it all three
phases then i go with garrett wilson but
felder the more and more i look at this
and i'm curious to see how he comes back
from injury and runs that's a big factor
in all of this but when you look at
drake london and then you look at zach
wilson's college tape zack wilson's
master class skill was giving his guys a
chance vertically with those back
shoulder balls they were abysmal and
contested catch situations last year the
name of the game for drake london is
contested catch situations so just
looking at his tape and how dominant it
was early in this half of the year i
would not rule him out in the top 10.
i i dig it let's get to the next 10 guys
like let's get to the next one and i
know we've got them highlighted here i
we we want to go from this we want to
talk about the dolphins too so we we're
showing you up we're getting to that's
into the next day we're going to we're
going to the dolphins let's go to the
dolphins
and i think the interesting thing with
the dolphins is
do you think they're in love with their
with their quarterback situation and
then are they willing to build around it
because obviously
going through what they went through
with brought not what they went through
but what they put brian flores through
like how does this situation shake out
i think it's one of those things where
you kind of smile shut up and nod your
head to your new boss until it blows up
right so
when you look at it from mike mcdaniel
he obviously wanted a head coaching job
and this was the one that was offered to
him so he took it and he's gonna try to
make it work with tua but this is an
uninspiring free agency move where it
tells me they're not ready to throw in
every last dollar and all their chips in
on tua just yet they want to see what
happens this year before they do that
which is a scary situation cedric wilson
is a nice number three wide receiver and
teddy bridgewater is obviously a backup
there if two gets hurt which we've seen
way too many times chase edmonds gives
you a pass catching back that is very
effective in bringing back manny ogba
who is really that green light has come
on as a pass rusher and we know what
kind of edge he sets as a run defender
is good for the defense but felder this
is starting to feel like a team that
with to a lingering there obviously an
owner and gm that we're all about
drafting him it's one foot in one foot
out and that's a scary situation to be
in in the nfl
it's tough and listen i'll i'll take the
blame for this i got him transposed i
had the dolphins when i should have had
the steelers so let's go to the steelers
before we go to go back to the comments
but let's go to the steelers uh an
interesting team they pick they acquire
mitch trubisky
uh you know unc stand up um
we'll see if you can stand out
as someone who went to unc
and then also
lives in chicago now
i've seen a lot of discussion regarding
trubisky from both sides where does he
fit for the steelers future plan and how
does he impact their draft
so father it was funny to me you just
can't escape this mitch schubiski
conversation but everybody reacted to
this move almost the exact opposite i
did when they reacted to it they said
the steelers got their quarterback right
and now you cannot worry about taking
one in in the draft and for me it was
the exact opposite when you dive into
the contract details mitch trubisky is
not being paid like a surefire starter
he's being paid more in the terms of a
high-end backup there's not long-term
guaranteed money and when you look at
the steelers situation
if they really do love malik willis
which is all we hear about the steelers
and you want to set up a situation for
malik willis to come in and have
long-term success you need a bridge guy
there that can run your offense give you
a chance and buy malik willis time to
get acclimated to the nfl and the mitch
trubisky signing to me was exactly for
that so now the steelers did part one
where they put in an infrastructure for
a young quarterback to come in sit learn
get better and be ready to go on all
cylinders when his name is called
but
now number two the hardest part where do
you have to go from 20 and i love what
they did on the offensive line let me
throw that in as well on top of this
young quarterback conversation where do
you have to go from 20 to go get malik
willis
yeah that's that's going to be the
question because we already have
referenced him to the panthers to the
falcons in that top ten if you're
sitting at 20 it's gonna be really hard
to get a guy that a lot of folks think
might end up in that top ten you're
gonna have to give some you're gonna
have to give some stuff up and
is that draft capital do they what
players do they have to give up that
make it worth their while to go up and
get them that's going to be really the
hard part of all this is figuring
weighing your options because
they're a team that is used to winning
they're used to being in the playoffs
they're used to competing they're used
like this the steelers and it's it's not
the same as in college football but the
steelers are a team that doesn't seem to
have the full reveal rebuild the way
that other teams do where they tear
everything down
yeah i think you absolutely nailed it
when you look at it right there for them
they now can't get leveraged if they
call somebody knows they have no choice
to come up because they didn't get a
quarterback now they did that with
trubisky i'll rip through a couple other
moves and then we're going to dive into
the comments before we get to the
ever-growing challenging afc west so you
see the chargers there at 17. they did a
great job traded for khalil mack signed
jc jackson uh got some interior
defensive line help as well now the door
is wide open for them felder if they
like jordan davis you take jordan davis
if you like jameson williams you say
jamison williams they're not pigeonholed
in the draft the eagles another one i
want to get to they have 15 19 um
obviously 16 as well they have a lot of
picks in this draft they gave hassan
reddick a ton of money an undersized but
super impactful pass rusher and i want
to know your take on this felder that to
me wipes the constant and i'm guilty of
this david ajabo mock drafted the eagles
you paid josh sweat you've paid hassan
reddick now you're going to look
elsewhere to improve your team
yeah i think you go in a different
direction there uh whether it's weapons
or it's it's upfront help i think you've
got to look somewhere else maybe it's
maybe it is that interior of the
defensive line though right like you're
getting guys they they need to beat that
part up so i think that's where they
they may end up looking whether that's
the guy like devonte wyatt who i
absolutely love and he should be there
right around that spot where they're
picking so he's a guy that i think goes
between probably 18 and 23. they're
right there in that mix so this is going
to be interesting to see how that fits
for them but and then hey what what do
you do do you go secondary is that the
place where we finally see safety start
to come off the board that's another
issue for me so i i love the way that
you're you're bringing it up because
we are seeing the complexion of the
draft be changed by veteran players and
i think that's something that is often
lost upon fans when they're watching a
mock draft they don't realize that oh
the mock drake well you mocked him to
hear yeah i had to change that
because they went out and got a guy that
can do that job so now they're looking
elsewhere they've cleared up their draft
board
they really did obviously fletcher cox
getting a little older it goes back to
your devonta wyatt pick interior the
offensive line getting a little older
maybe that's where tyler linderbaum
comes into play and we're going to bring
him up in just a little bit let's check
in on the comments i want to go back to
the dolphins here
smurf smurf311 came in and said what is
miami's biggest draft need running back
tackle edge pass rush and what and that
was a question and what player in the
first round is most likely to get
drafted in miami so felder for me as
much as bruce hall would be a lot of fun
in that offense i don't think it's a
luxury they can afford in the first
round you're probably gonna have to wait
until the second round
yes they need a tackle but they are not
in range for some of the guys we're
gonna talk about early on today they're
more in the trevor pending tyler smith
bernard raymond kind of range so if
you're a miami fan and you're thinking
offensive line hang with us we're gonna
get through all that as well but felder
can you make an argument for a round one
running back for the dolphins
no i tried i got i got like i i was like
yeah i'm gonna do it and then i was like
no i can't like i just i don't think
they're gonna be able to do it i don't
think that and it's a combination of
things right it's confluence of multiple
things it's i don't think there's a
running back in this draft that i
that based upon current nfl standards is
a first round running back and then the
other part of it is i don't think i
think they've got to find a way to fix
other things and so
maybe this is a jabo right maybe this is
where we see someone like him come off
the board maybe
that's the that's that instead of him
being mocked to the eagles maybe he
should be getting back to the dolphins
maybe that's that's what happens but i
think finding a way to get to the
quarterback i think protecting your
quarterback i think those things are
more paramount than
the idea of getting a running back
running back you're gonna be able to get
a lot of run rates we've already done
our running back show right we've
already done the running back show
you're gonna be able to get a running
back later you'll be able to get a good
running back later a really good running
back later quite honestly
maybe you can get brian robinson later
who i i
was watching more of him this week
connor
i really like him i think he's really
good
yeah like he's so good like he's he he
is he feels to me a little bit like a
like uh like like kroger brand mark
ingram you know what i mean like he can
do everything well and he's always going
to be around and he's just going to keep
going and going and going no he's never
going to be you're you're all pro guy
but you know what he is going to be he's
going to be a guy that blocks he's going
to be a guy that can catch out of the
backfield to be a safety valve and he
knows where he's what he's supposed to
do all of his marks when he runs he's a
really good player so yeah i think you
wait around and you can still get good
talent at the running back spot
all right let's get back into the
comments here we have from rick sauter
who asked what team could target a
quarterback that no one is expecting to
target a quarterback when i look at this
quickly felder we've gone through a lot
of different scenarios for the
quarterbacks teams that we have not
discussed maybe the vikings at 12. and i
know they just gave kirk cousins another
year on his deal so he's under contract
for 2022 and 2023
but maybe if they want to take somebody
that's a little raw like a malik willis
at 12 although i don't think he gets
there or maybe they look at you know
later on rounds and they believe in
whether it's a desmond ritter whether
it's a sam howell whoever it may be the
vikings are one of those teams for me so
felder what do you think of maybe a
surprise team or my thought of the
vikings looking at this quarterback
class
so i'll do the vikings first i i
literally my mind immediately went to
sam howell um
he's kind of the opposite of cousins in
that he the thing that he doesn't do as
well is like to hit those intermediate
and in between the hash mark throws but
what he really does is throw the deep
ball and stretch you down the field
which is exciting and then he but to get
picked behind him to have time to
develop to develop the ability to throw
between the hashes to hit the interior
would help him out because he is a
quality quarterback he can throw the
deep ball as well as anybody else he's
got the ability to stretch down the
field he's athletic so i think that's an
interesting one for me as far as and
look we're looking at sam howell right
now by the way love those uniforms but
look at the way he's able to evade eyes
downfield tell point tell him where to
go and then just deliver and he puts the
ball out in front doesn't throw the
defense back into it that's the thing
honestly i think kind of the thing i
like the most about hal
is that he very rarely throws the
defense back into the play
and that's something that
goes a long way i don't think a lot of
folks think about that nearly enough but
when you throw a deep ball there's a lot
of quarterbacks have the tendency to be
terrified to miss long
and guess what if you miss short the
defense has a chance to get back into
the play to break that thing up or even
create a pass interference either way
your guy didn't catch the ball and you
certainly didn't score a touchdown so
for how i love that element to his game
i think it's going to continue as he
gets to the next level as far as
man a team that could sneak up for a
quarterback i
that's a tough one because
i don't think anybody's fallen in love
with after malik willis
i think teams like kenny pickett i think
teams like desmond ritter but i don't
think anybody's fallen in love with
these guys down the line and that's
where
if you're not in love with them you're
not going to use your first round pick
on them so i'm curious to see how long
they stick in because i think the only
thing that's driving teams it's not love
it's need
and so if you're a team that doesn't
need a quarterback and you're not in
love with a quarterback then you
certainly don't take a quarterback
all right i'll throw in last one for
maximum chaos felder i know he's got a
lot of dead money tied to him in the
next two years but maybe the titans with
ryan tannehill maybe they go we like you
ryan tannehill but we know
he's gonna be a sneaky 35 years old
after this season at quarterback and
obviously that money will come off the
books so maybe the titans although like
you said it's need it's not talent so
all right let me dive back into the
comments one more time before we move on
to the afc west uh we got plenty of good
stuff in here i saw a shout out about br
hoodies that i just lost so thank you
whoever said br hoodies are comfortable
all right rzr bk fan 88 said how can the
cowboys not draft trayland berks with
their first pick since getting rid of
half of their wide receivers he is
alluding to the trade of amari cooper
and losing cedric wilson in free agency
yes they got cd lamb yes they extended
michael gallop felder when you look at
treylin burks and you look at how the
cowboys love having three
borderline number one wide receivers do
you see the fit here
i see a fit and i mean
you think those arkansas fans the
arkansas fans aren't cowboys fans too
they show up there every year
so they're going to be thrilled if he
ends up there i think the key is going
to be what else do they need and connor
you tell me what else do they need what
would stop them from picking berks as a
guy that could absolutely help this
football team as he learns the space
with c i love cd land by the way and
gallup is amazing but i love cd lamb
like
what you get one guy who's an absolute
crazy finesse acrobat in cd lam and then
you another guy who's a a total bruiser
with with some with them swiss sweet
feet in in in burke and like but what's
not to love about that what would they
what what else would they draft that
they need that would stop them from
getting him
offensive line they've dealt with a lot
of blows to this offensive line and it's
not as fun as traelyn burks i'll be the
first one to admit that it's not as fun
as thinking about cd in the slot gallop
and trailing berks these big small
forwards on the outside that win the
jump ball over and over again and like
felder said bruisers that can run
through you the problem is felder tyron
smith that left tackle's fine even
though he's gotten older and had some
injuries that's not a problem
zach martin a right guard that's not a
problem they're gonna move on from lyle
collins that's a giant hole at right
tackle they don't have a left guard
right now they just lost connor williams
in free agency so what are they gonna be
doing it there when you look at those
two holes felder i kind of start to
defer to two names kenyan green and
obviously zion because when you look at
what they've done
they both play tackle and guard and
they've both done it at a high level so
for me the cowboys almost by default
have to be thinking offensive line but
the trailing berks pick is more fun
yeah
you're spot on it's more fun but yeah
you know what you taught me back i mean
also but if you can get kenyan green
he's a beast and do you think they'd be
able you know you know i'll save it i'll
say let's just let's save the offensive
line talk let's save the offensive line
talk for later okay because we are going
to get into green we're going into zion
we're going to get into all those guys
and we we just did the comments right so
we're going to what the afc west is that
was that what's next on the dock
yeah take us to the afc west felder
we're starting with the chargers
yeah chargers chiefs raiders broncos
starting with the chargers chargers
i mean
we you look we already talked about what
they did in free agency this is a team
that needs a defensive tackle they need
some tight end help they need a guard
the question that i posed to you
uh i put it into the dock and i wanted
to ask you is is 17 too early for trey
mcbride
i think so i think because you can get
him in the second round which is great
right if you're sitting there as the
chargers looking at that situation and
you might have to move obviously looking
at how the bears hold that 48th pick
because of the khalil mack trade you
might have to come back into round two
if you're the chargers because they
don't hold the second round pick but i
think it's 17 felder you could play the
value game a little bit i think you can
look at jameson williams and get
vertical right and
you know how i look at it is the chess
match right everybody in that division
got a second pass rusher pass rusher
that's a number one right they have joey
bosa they got khalil mack obviously you
look at the raiders they had max crosby
and then they get chandler jones
everybody's kind of playing that game
the broncos they obviously have bradley
chubb then they got randy gregory now
everybody's looking at it that way but
everybody's also loading up on weapons
right now the chiefs have always had a
lot of weapons you look at the chargers
yes they brought back mike williams and
they have keenan allen there
but do you go get g and you see
sebastian joseph day helps your interior
defensive line to stop the run that was
a big worry for me so why not load up
why not get vertical with jameson
williams let mike williams and keenan
allen play on the outside you can
stretch the field and then you have the
run game the short pass game to austin
eckler the chargers are in the driver's
seat to make it a nightmare for opposing
defenses
yeah i'm looking forward to what they do
i i had to ask the trey mcbride question
and
he'll carry us over into the chiefs as
well as a team that is still interested
in tight end so hey listen you talk
about being in the driver's seat they're
in the driver's seat of this division
and when you have patmo homes when
you're a team that's been to the super
bowl when you're ready to rock and roll
uh when you look at them
who do you see them taking because i
think trey mcbride is an option at the
end of the first round if you really
like him but the other question i had
for you
verone mckinley or brian cook in round
two what do you think about that
i love where you're going with that
felder and you see mick bride here the
ability to win at the catch point all
the time he literally doesn't drop
passes he's a high effort run blocker
you can get him on the move
i mean the concentration is truly absurd
from trey mcbride he was their offense
that's how they ran their offense
through and all of it as
as dominant as travis kelsey is
once again he's not getting any younger
right he's going to turn 33 early in the
season and
everybody in the nfl runs 12 personnel
now right all the good teams they all
have two tight ends that can block run
catch so it's you're just making the
rich get richer in that situation but i
want to go to your round two point right
they signed justin reed that's a big
time move when you look at the chief
step char and they needed help on the
back end because they are not bringing
back tyron matthew the honey badger so i
look at the value safeties i like brian
cook a lot but felder i'm also looking
at corner now for them because they can
roll out with justin reed as more of
your in the box safety you have juan
thornhill that can play deep you see
what they've been able to do for agency
yes they you know obviously they lost
javarius ward to the 49ers they have
significant holes at both corner spots
here felder where i think back into
round one you kind of got to be hoping
and praying stingley's not going to be
there sauce gardner is not going to be
there i would say there's a 20
chance trent mcduffie uh will make it
there that's not very high so felder i
think all eyes at the back end of round
one are now on
kyler gordon roger mccreery uh andrew
booth who's fighting some injuries and
wasn't able to test the clemson pro day
today but that's where my my my mind is
at for the chiefs defensive backfield
where do you throw kobe bryant in that
mix with booth and the rest of those
guys i love it
i love it and i think kobe bryant goes
right back to your brian cook
conversation ironically playing in the
same secondary uh where you can get him
potentially a pick 62 which for the
cheat and kobe bryant to me is a
starting corner from day one so i think
when you can get that at the end of the
second round that's significant value
for me so i love that you bring in kobe
bryant he's somebody to me that uh can
have success in both man and zone
coverage he has really patient eyes and
knows how to play the football knows how
to find the football at the highest
point so i like where you're going with
that let's keep this moving chiefs
chargers obvious powerhouses but we are
not done there i think
we have to talk about these raiders and
then obviously the broncos but the
raiders who kind of get laughed at in
this division despite making the
playoffs here they made big moves felder
they went out and got chandler jones
across from max crosby they traded
unique and gawkway to get rocky sin
and then you see it right there they've
been able to make some big-time
additions to their db area that needs a
lot of help felder i'm looking for
somebody to play between chandler jones
and max crosby with that 20-second
overall pick devonte wyatt is the name
that comes to mind for me
[Music]
yeah i love we all know i love devonta
wyatt so i think he's a guy that can
play probably from a zero to a four i uh
depending on what you know what
formation what calls you want to run how
you want to work structure your blitz
package he can do all those things he's
explosive off the ball uh he's got the
ability to to move the line of scrimmage
or to penetrate and get behind the line
of scrimmage and i love all those things
about him this is the guy that wants to
look at his patience understands he's
mirroring the quarterback and then he's
going to give you some effort to go out
and run and make sure he's trying to
make a play he doesn't make the tackle
where he wants to make a tackle but he's
slapping the ball out i love that about
him he's he's gonna check all your boxes
and i think he's someone that's got
there's the penetration that we talked
about he's got a lot of benefit to his
game his stock rose in a tremendous way
i guess the question for me to you is
if you're sitting there at 22.
do you think jordan davis will still be
on the board to make this a harder pick
do you think somebody will already
decide which georgia defensive tackle to
take for the raiders based upon davis
already being off the board
it's a great question i think he'll be
gone i think jordan davis will be gone
but it's gonna be a close call like i
said that conversation might start at 14
uh with the ravens the chargers at 17 as
well and then i also wonder felder with
wyatt the pass rush juice that he should
and there was a really good clip on
there of his ability to get off the ball
he almost gets off the ball too fast
almost i came across offsides that's how
quick he is off the ball
it's tough for guards to even get into
their pass set against him and get their
hands ready that's how quick he is you
know we've seen a lot of defensive
tackles that have been drafted really
high in recent years you think of quinn
williams and ed oliver then went in the
top 10 of their prospective draft
classes that's what teams love with
their first round d tackles felder is
getting off the ball creating pass rush
but also blowing up the run
yeah i love ed oliver i'm glad you
mentioned him in there because that's
i'm seeing little mini at oliver things
i don't think he's as developed as as
far as move counter move or set up move
to the counter move regarding devonta
white compared to ed oliver but i do
think he's got some of that
relentlessness and the ability to make
himself small to fit to to create
penetration and get onto the other side
of the line of scrimmage
all right let's talk about the team that
stole all the headlines pretty early in
this nfl league year by acquiring
russell wilson right we knew they were
all in on aaron rodgers it didn't work
rogers goes back to green bay the denver
broncos make the big splash and they pay
a hefty price but fortunately for the
broncos as much as when teams trade for
franchise quarterbacks and lose all
their picks because of the von miller
trade they do pick it 64. so keep that
in mind for this conversation but felder
we talked about it a little earlier when
you look at the broncos they got the
skill talent they got rust the defense
is absolutely loaded they
added randy gregory and dj jones
excellent front four players that can
both rush can both defend the run adding
that to bradley chubb i look at that
right tackle spot there felder that's
the big hole and for a guy like russ
that's getting older has been injured in
recent years has a smaller body type you
got to be able to protect him they got
to be thinking of lyle collins or at 64
dive into this offensive line class
yeah i listen we're going to hit sean
ryan we're going to talk about some of
these other guys i i think the other
part is
is there a defensive tackle that's 64
that you like more than them finding one
of these offensive line prospects
you know it depends who you're looking
for because we know this jordan davis
and devonte wyatt the georgia boys
they're going to be gone travis jones
from uconn he's going to be gone now do
you want an attacking three tech are you
going to look at logan hall from houston
are you going to look at perrian winfrey
from oklahoma is that the kind of player
you want or do you want a all right take
it away felder you i said winfrey and
your eyes lit up what are you thinking
here
winfrey was listen i got in trouble i
was doing a show and i was like oklahoma
doesn't have really any good defensive
players except for what nick benito and
they're like perry winfrey parent wifey
first round draft pick and i was like so
i made a point all year to pay attention
to him
and he is
i mean this guy is he's a boop-boop
he's up and down up and down up and down
up and down and it's
he's
built if you looked at him just in his
pads and his jersey he looks like a five
tank
and then they play him on the interior
and i don't know if he's playing out of
position
or i think if they're using him in a
different you think he's so i'm not
crazy okay i'm not crazy right
like he no i should have been able to do
a couple defensive linemen about this
and they because they really liked him
at the senior bowl where he was
unblockable felder literally it didn't
matter who was in front of him he was
unblockable and everybody's like where
was this in oklahoma so you asked people
that actually played defensive line and
they're like they didn't use him right
so you're all over it
okay i i was like i'm not crazy like
this he he he he shines and then he
disappears and shines and disappears and
i was like
why can't this guy just be like
collapsing the line closing from the
edge holding off guys he's got long arms
hold off guys with those long arms have
your outside arm free to make tackles
and i just i don't know i don't i don't
know that he's i don't know if he's a
three technique or not which is that's
that's the thing i think he's better as
a four eye i think he can play as a five
i think he's a four i or a five and for
folks that don't understand that's one
guy can play sort of inside of that
tackle the other guy plays on the
outside of that tackle but he's got the
ability to do or outside of the guard
inside or outside of the guard outside
of the tackle but he's got the ability
to do those things i think the
interesting part for him is going to be
where he fits actually at the next level
because he's super talented it's just a
matter of usage for him and
with the broncos currently and what
feels like win now mode i don't know
that that's the developmental pick that
they want to take so
connor take us to the comments and then
we agree that broncos need to take an
offensive lineman at that 64 pick so
let's talk about some offensive lineman
after we hit the comments yeah we
absolutely do all right the comments
mcat 93 still rocking with us kobe
bryant is a steal in the second round
felder and i obviously agree we like
kobe bryant a lot uh desert zombie says
so charger is going to pass up davis if
he's there at 17. i don't think that's a
lock even though with all their signings
they still could take jordan davis 17.
moose maxwell 31 said devonte wyatt to
kansas city sorry moose he's not making
it that far in this draft all right one
here that i do want to get into that you
know we kind of didn't touch
b douglas 6 says raiders need speed at
wide receiver i agree if they don't go
into your defensive line at 22 jamison
williams is not going to be there felder
do you look at chris salabe do you look
at johan dotson do you look at christian
watson this is a team that is missing a
big time vertical threat from their
offense we know josh mcdaniels needs
that but will there be any options at
22. it feels a little like no man's land
in the draft
if a lava is there you got to take him i
i i i like jahan datsun more than i like
olave
but i will under i will see the fact
that olave is a better all-around wide
receiver
uh he's he's so fast he does everything
i think they both have a great
understanding of spacing on the field i
think olave's just a little better
and
but again i like datsun more so if it's
me and i'm at what is it 22 you said
yep if it's if it's me at 22
personally i hope the lobby's gone that
way i can pick datsun because i really
really like him and i like what he
brings to the table i love the fact that
he was their offense essentially this
past season where he had to do almost
everything i love his toughness he
please a guy that's not tall but he
plays like he's he plays like he's 6'5
and i love that about him i think a lave
far more hell to pay on a crossing route
than dodson but dotson finds a way to
create space he's a he's a
listen i don't know if there's a lot of
gamers out there folks that love metal
gear snake eater but i've been calling
john dodson uh he's metal gear solid
space eater where he just finds space in
zones eats it up takes it away gets gets
the ball gets the first down and then
gets down because he he's smart the guy
is a smart football player and i want to
make sure when we when we encounter guys
that i really think are super have super
high football accused we mentioned it
because he does a lot of really smart
things when he runs routes he
understands
i can't i i can't tail this route to 15
i have to keep it at 12 because if i go
to 15 the safety's gonna be able to
sneak me so i keep it at 12 and now i
got an opportunity after or i have to
run this route to 15 because there's a
corner sitting underneath me and i got
to get my quarterback time to get the
ball up and over so that's why i like
datsun but i do think olave if olav is
there you have to take him because he
can run every single route in the book
i love it felder and a little spoiler
alert i think alave goes at 21 to the
patriots which is kind of ironic they
might get sniped if they want him i
think that's a seamless fit in the nfl
draft in new england's been all over him
in this pre-draft process all right we
talked about the broncos and that need
for right tackle now we're gonna get
into most of the offensive linemen in
this draft and how they can help your
team and
you really gotta start with the blue
chip prospects right because this is a
class that has been built on the
offensive line talent the premium
offensive line talent the guys that are
foundational anchors and that's where we
start this off we talked about evan neal
right and we'll continue that
conversation here pretty rare territory
how he carries that weight there's not a
lot of guys that are six foot seven that
play tackle that almost look like a
unicorn tight end in a sense whether
it's his feet whether it's his arms evan
neal has put it all together he started
a garden 2019 right tackle in 2020 left
tackle in 2021
felder this is somebody that not only
looks like a number one overall pick but
he has played like a number one overall
pick he's gonna measure that way as well
and i think he's gonna have an
incredible pro day when he goes through
the athletic testing there
yeah when he wants to be a bully he
could be a bully and when he wants to be
you know sweet feet and nimble he can do
those things too and i like his punch
his extension is great he keeps the guys
off his body doesn't let him get into
his chest he does a really good job with
all those things and i think obviously
you see there the ability to kind of
pass off a twist and catch a guy and
give his quarterback a chance to make a
play i think he does he checks every
single box there's not a box that evan
neil doesn't check i think that watching
him is he's the best all-around
offensive lineman in this group i'm
gonna kick it to you connor to get to
our next blue chipper guy uh ike miguano
from nc state uh right up the road from
where i'm from right right there in
raleigh so uh you look at him and
this is a guy i know we've got the
bruiser category coming up in a little
bit but if he wasn't a blue chip he'd
fit into the bruisers he's just a blue
chip bruiser
he really is a blue that's a perfect way
to put it a blue chip bruiser bully is
ika mekwanu i talked about earlier on
the show you just don't see
the ability to get out of your you know
into your stance and move the way he
does but controlled movement where he
knows how to lock onto guys and this
isn't low level competition this is
mississippi state okay and he is making
this look like pop warner tape i think
with a kwanu what we get so excited
about felder is that impact run blocking
at the first second even third level of
the field but quietly why he's in this
conversation to be a top five pick in
this draft which he will be i don't
think he'll make it past number four
with the new york jets he definitely
wouldn't make it past number five with
the new york giants he started to figure
it out as a pass protector on the edge
felder he started to align his feet with
his shoulders get into his pass sets a
little bit more smoothly not over set
allow guys to get inside and start to
really time his hands and his punch and
that's the thing that we don't talk
about because maybe it's not great for
the highlights but for a kwanu it's
what's turned him into a developmental
bruiser former big time wrestler great
athlete into a bonafide polished top end
prospect
well that's what i that's what i like
about him is is watching the development
i love seeing these guys grow year over
year over year and watching him the
ability to to be patient enough to pass
off a twist as you mentioned not over
setting but he's he's he's got the
ability to pass off twist he's got the
ability to get set protect the interior
while reaching to the exterior of the
offensive line not giving not giving
away as a left tackle not giving away
his right side
and still being able to push to get to
that to expand to get to the left side i
think that's a really phenomenal talent
that he's continuing to accrue there's a
and i also you know what
i love his attitude man like screw it i
love his attitude like this is a guy we
saw it in the tape right there right
where he gets guys down on the ground
and he
he's if the play is still going he's
looking for work but if the play is done
he's looking at your face and letting
you know by the way dude you just got
messed up i did that to you like there's
a play against south florida where he
just absolutely destroys some guy and as
he's running to look for more more play
for somebody else to block he bullies
the guy to the ground points at him he
goes yep and then keeps going and i was
like this guy's got the attitude that
you want he's a tone setter and that's
kind of what you want along the front um
you mentioned mississippi state i guess
we got to get to charles cross right
like he's another guy like are we going
to see three these three guys all go in
the top ten
i think we are the only one that could
fall out is charles cross and i don't
really have the answer for you why
because when i watch him felder this is
not your typical mike leech kind of
tackle right that's if anybody says that
to you uh ignore them immediately this
is a true franchise left tackle with
gifted gifted light feet he really moves
like a move tight end but he has the
strength of an offensive and there it is
i mean
he just glides right to a linebacker
right there when you can glide it's the
long stride it's the controlled hands i
actually was joking with somebody when i
dove into charles cross's tape as a pass
protector it almost lulls you to sleep
because of how perfect rep after rep
after rep and i think that frustrates
rushers and and the icing on the cake
here felder is that he tests he comes in
and he measures well 34 and a half inch
arms that is well above the threshold
for a tackle a four nine five forty uh
that is flying that is elite speed at
307 pounds so charles cross i think he's
going to show people he has a lot unt a
lot of untapped potential as a run
blocker that he didn't get to show at
the college level this year but the past
protection to keep your quarterback
upright is so key
yeah he's really good at pass pro and i
listen i'm glad that you mentioned this
is not a typical leech offensive lineman
this is he's not the incredible bulk
right he's not just a huge guy that
makes people run around him so they can
get the ball out in 2.8 seconds or
whatever this is a guy that he's got
sweet feet he's he's swift he's got this
nimbleness to his game he again he looks
like that he's got a basketball player
build you mentioned move tight in but
he's clearly this guy looks like a
basketball player like he's he's tall
and strong and he's got the ability to
move around i think that we'll see the
strength be tested and that's where i
think teams will
try to attack him once he's at the next
level they'll try to load up on that
side with with a heavy defensive end and
and try to see if they can move him
around and control him in the run game
to condense things down but the reality
of it is if you're in pass pro he's
going to be he's he's going to bother
you non-stop so that you have to you're
not going to be able to run the hump
against him he's much fat he's going to
be faster and you're not going to be
able to get inside because he's going to
be able to come back down and push you
wash you all the way down inside because
he understands the technicalities of the
game
another blue chip guy well
controversial blue chip guy if you will
tyler lindenbaum from iowa i know you
have them in the blue chip category we
have them in the technician category
this is our new technician uh category
what's keeping him out of the blue chip
category is it just is it merely his
position
yeah felder it's it's nothing that he
can control he was just born with it he
was born that he's gonna play at 290
pounds and he's about six foot one and
he plays center and that combination
the latter one playing center alone
typically keeps you out of the top 10 of
the nfl draft it's not necessarily
something that i personally agree with i
think for a young quarterback the center
comes in often calls out protections can
change your run game the quickest route
to the quarterback
is the zero over the center that's how
you get to the coin it's basic math it's
basic geometry uh when you look at it
though with linder bonfelder everything
is super smooth right it's not just the
ability that how explosive he is in the
run game uh but once again how polished
he is with the strong hands you see the
state championship wrestling background
with the toughness on the field and the
fact that he's a people mover he gets
his hands and always wins leverage and
maybe the size helps with that felder i
don't think i want a center out there
that's six five six foot six i like his
center to be low center gravity plays
down into the ground gets his hands
right up from under you and moves you
out of the way and that is a highlight
reel run block right there so felder you
or i if we were in a draft room tyler
linderbaum is a no-brainer top 15 pick
in this year's class
yeah well the problem is we're not so
we're gonna have to probably wait a
little bit to hear his name called but i
love him too i i'm glad you mentioned
the leverage i love that he starts from
a low center of gravity pushes up gets
that six inch rising blow gets into your
chest gets underneath your pads and then
you see guys start to get puffed up and
all of a sudden now you don't have us
you don't you have no center of gravity
because you're up in the air next thing
you know you're on your back and you
can't be a bug on the rug if you're if
you're going to play good football and
that's what he creates he creates bugs
on the rug and it's a real he's a really
good football player also on this list i
think we got to go to bc right zion
johnson another technician another
technic i don't understand how bc keeps
doing it but they do right it doesn't
matter who the head coach is doesn't
even matter who the offensive line coach
is they keep creating guys that just can
get the job done so where do we see zion
johnson uh where do we see him fitting
into
this nfl draft i know you've got him as
a top 40 is he a guy that listen top 40
that's
what is that eight picks away from being
in the in the in the first round like
where does he fit
i think he doesn't make it out of the
first round felder i think it starts
with the cardinals at 23 the cowboys at
24. uh the titans who moved on from
roger saffold during this free agency
period at 26. the bucks at 27. the
dolphins at 29. when you have all of
those teams that need a guard who a guy
that was fine at tackle and was great at
guard and has had a long road and then
they have snapping the ball at the
senior ball
this guy is he's a a lock to be a really
good guard at the next level his build
is like a tree trunk right he just it's
hard to move him and when he can get
like blender bomb when he can get
leverage to get up under you you're
gonna go backwards and i think for zion
that's such a key the weight room work
that he's done the ability to pull find
a target lock onto a target and
absolutely devour them and that's going
to make a big difference in the run game
get those feet moving get him churning
uphill and zion is going to be a first
round pick in this year's draft
yeah i think so too i think the kid's
really good and watching him just play
in the acc and get the job done and
again you mentioned that the scheme
versatility the position versatility
tackle he can help you tackle he's a
guard he's probably going to be a guard
but he's going to be able to help you a
tackle if you need him which allows you
to slice somebody in else somebody else
in a guard which is going to be really
good sean ryan who we've already mocked
to the broncos right at that 64th pick i
think he fits into this mix as well i
think chip kelly did a really good job
with um
positioning him
in terms of what they asked him to do he
was one of the only high profile guys
and i think chip kelly's first class and
he came in was almost immediately a
contributor and you watch the tape if
you guys would pull it up you see what
he's able to do he's someone that can go
out and just he looks for work he can
move you off the point but look at that
leverage look at that look at the look
at the pad level right this is a guy
that's playing flat back football he
wants to push you out of the way and
make things happen and i love that about
him look at him i'm underneath you i'm
underneath you and then he keeps going i
think that's really good i think that
for him as long whenever as long as he
keeps that pad level low he's got
got good things going on you see him now
washing down two guys creating a space
and this is against again you mentioned
uh iguano against mississippi state that
was against lsu we know there are no
slouches so i think this is an
interesting guy that fits into sort of
that technician realm because when his
pad level's good he's really tough to
beat
yeah there's something about a guy that
wins the left tackle job as a freshman
and then carries it for three years and
there's a little bit of poking and
prodding with where he plays the next
level because
this is fascinating to me felder 32 and
3 8 inch arms that's under the threshold
that's typical for a tackle but 11 and 1
8 inch hands those are monster paws and
you just showed it on film when he can
lock on to somebody uh he can get them
moving in the dire right direction i
think he carries that mass really really
well so let's keep this moving in the
next category we're going to look at the
bruisers and i'm going to group them in
two here felder we'll start with kenyan
green who we talked a lot about the show
he's played left tackle left guard right
guard right tackle is
you know looking like a first round lock
whether it's the cowboys or one of the
other teams i mentioned for guards and
tyler smith
my goodness when you look at bruiser
tyler smith actually started playing
offensive line late in high school it
was not his original position he goes
out there and is just looking to maul
while trying to clean up some of those
technical flaws he has but he is such a
bully that it often doesn't matter when
you see these two players here folder
felder what is it that you just love
about their tape
well let's let's start with tyler smith
i mean i love the fact that he's just
like listen once i got you i got you
it's over
like there's nothing you can do about it
you can't there's like it's literally
was a predator too there's no stopping
what can't be stopped
and he just once he gets you it's on
he's got to work on keeping his hands in
the frame right we see him get a little
wide sometimes but once he has you it's
game over you're done you're buried and
then with kenyan green the thing for me
and i know you love him but with king
and green his versatility to play all
those positions
it there's a lot of different technique
involved in playing guard first playing
tackle there's different things that you
have to do with tackle you only have
help to one side you don't have help to
the other side and so it's very he's
a bruiser but i think he's a little more
polished of a bruiser than smith because
he still has had to play that tackle
spot but i think he's best at guard and
i think he's going to be someone who's
who's moving bodies getting guys out of
the way and let me tell you something i
think he's one of those guys where
you get to camp and i know we're going
to get to jabari sawyer as well but he's
one of those guys where you get to camp
and there's a vet who's like oh no like
a veteran defensive tackle is like oh
man
this kid's good
yeah i think that speaks volumes all
right moving on to we had kenyon green
and tyler smith i think they're going in
the first round now we'll look at uh
jamari salier and darian canard i'll
start with canard because felder sawyer
is absolutely your guy i mean the
bruiser category it's the street fight
category right and that's what canard
looks for he played right tackle in
college i do think he should play guard
at the next level i don't think his feet
are quick enough in his pass sets to
constantly protect that edge on the
right side i know that will be a big
time debate uh leading up to the draft
and for whatever team takes him but
finishing your run blocks is what canard
does and i think that sets a different
tone on the field it's not just you know
i'm gonna look to move you out of the
way or i'm gonna you know kind of do
this half rep he's looking to lock on to
you and keep you moving keep those legs
going down the field keeps it keeps his
arms extended a very girthy base and you
see that play into the power against
undersized defensive ends because he
carries a lot of mass so when you look
at kinard and even sawyer i think these
are two guys that
thrived at tackle at the college level
they were fine tackles but they can
unlock a pro bowl level at guard in the
nfl
yeah i think you're spot on and we saw
that in the national championship game
with respect to sawyer sawyer was
someone who started all games at left
tackle and they were like we're having
some real problems on the interior
against alabama what are we going to do
oh we'll move our starting left tackle
to right guard and then next thing we
know we've got a james cook 64-yard run
that blows the game wide open we're in
business now baby so i think that sawyer
is
i mean he's built like um the first time
i ever saw him he was in high school
uh and he he reminds me man this kid he
looks like raphael uh like the ninja
turtle like
just a huge like body with a little head
on top of it like a tank you know like a
little head on top yeah but he's a body
mover he's a people mover as you
mentioned he is a bruiser in every sense
of the word he is going to get you out
of the way and he is looking for work
and he looks to punish i love what he
brings to the table
i think i think he's a first round guy i
i've said that already i think that he
is severely underrated by people i think
he's going to end up and if it's guard
great he's going to end up being
somebody's guard for eight years and
they're gonna no one's gonna think about
that position and
until he's gone and then you're like oh
wait what what happened what what what
why why so i love jamari solar he's one
of my favorites uh connor i'll take us
to the next one right and this is the
one that's i think i find this to be the
most intriguing
it's the developmental and we talk
developmental guys and what we mean by
that are guys that they have the tools
they have the measurables they have the
ability it's about putting it all
together
that's exactly right felder and that
conversation starts with trevor penning
maybe the biggest riser of the offensive
line class this year when you're coming
from a school like northern iowa we've
seen offensive line talent come out of
the school with spencer brown who
started at right tackle for the bills
last year with penning who is going to
go in the first round but he's not a
first round player for me here's the
measurables right six foot seven 325 34
and a quarter inch arms that's tackle
tackle tackle right across the board
there 48 940 is freakish so we know this
guy can move and he loves to chop it up
until and through and after the whistle
he just loves to fight that's what he
does
on the field at the college level that's
what he did on the practice field at the
senior bowl now felder for me
the question i have with penning and a
guy that's six seven a skyscraper is
often gonna deal with this the anchor
the leverage i think everything else is
fine the length but when you can get
under and in his pads and move him
backwards where nfl defensive lineman
they're gonna have the strength to do
that that's something he needs to work
on do you think that is a a skill you
can project and something you can get
better at or when you're that tall and a
little bit upright it's always going to
be an issue
well i think the nail on the head for
you that you mentioned is a little bit
upright right we're not talking about
that same issue with evan neal he's six
seven no uh we're we're talking about it
with with penning because penny seems to
be a little more upright as a player and
that's something that you have to get
out of your system i think the big issue
for him is more he's always been the
biggest stronger he's or not always but
he's currently the biggest and the
strongest so he doesn't have to do
things the right way all the time which
is why he's in the developmental
category uh once you start going against
defensive lineman that can transition
speed to power once you start going
against guys that don't just bull rush
or guys that don't just uh that don't
just try to run outside of you and you
start going against guys that work a
long arm guys that have a setup move now
you have to realize that i've got to
sink my hips and that's where we're
going to see if penny can develop that i
hope he gets with a good offensive line
coach that helps him understand how to
sink those hips not bend at the waist
but sink his hips so that he doesn't end
up with a with kayvon thibodeaux's you
know
right hand
in his chest getting lifted up
with that speed to power ratio that we
love to see out of a good defensive end
so that's going to be an interesting
part for him uh let's go to bernard
raymond man um
from central michigan another guy that's
on the developmental list he's is he do
you think he's a late day two guy or is
he a day three player
belter i wouldn't be surprised if
somebody took him at the end of round
one and i think that's a little insane
to me right now but i have heard buzz
that he you see right there the
projection top 40 i think if he falls
out of round one somebody will come up
in the beginning of day two to get him
all right here's the good right
transition from tight end to tackle uh
during the pandemic so he's only been in
this transition for about two years and
he's been able to put on a lot of mass
to that athletic body he's from austria
so he is not a lifer in terms of
football there is
some untapped potential there and he
loved the bully block right there six
foot six 303 arms are under that 33-inch
threshold which teams will question that
as a long-term tackle that's when teams
start to go do you have the length and
it's not just the measurement here
felder when you watch him at the senior
bowl gives up that outside shoulder a
lot and tackles that do that when they
can't chop their feet with the shoulder
the ones that can make up for it got
these long arms makai becton is the one
that comes to mind he couldn't always
move his feet with his shoulders but
when your arm goes all the way to the
ceiling it doesn't matter because you
can cut a guy off i think with raymond
you see those short arms come into play
sometimes where he gives up that outside
shoulder to the guys that can ghost move
right they can get off the ball dip the
shoulder it's a ghost move because you
never see them you never touch them and
then they're haunting your quarterback
okay so that's my question about raymond
right now
man see that's wow man that's
the other thing becca was how big how
big's becton he's huge oh that's in six
seven with like 35-inch arms
yeah like he but he's also like a huge
body guy like he's big like wide we're
talking about a converted tight end
that's played a year and a half of
football at the tackle spot man that
just that's why i like to me i think he
certainly should be a dangerous guy i am
yes
yes
developmental it's just wild to me but
like
he's shown some good stuff on film i
think the interesting part is going to
be
i think there's a double-edged sword
here because
he hasn't played the position that long
that's a positive and a negative the
negative part is he doesn't know what
he's doing
the positive part is he doesn't have a
lot of bad habits that people pick up
along the way so he's fully coachable
still i mean if you're talking about a
guy that's only played with something
like 18 games in at one spot you've got
an opportunity to mold him into what you
want which i guess that will get
offensive line coaches offensive
coordinators excited which while he
could creep up i still think he's more
of a day two guy but we'll see how that
shapes up uh who else we got we got max
mitchell right here right we got max
mitchell coming up
another guy um from louisiana i almost
called it lafayette i know they don't
like that so i won't do it um but
he's someone and they played in a system
similar to what we saw out of
mississippi state right and this is a
guy that i think he has the athleticism
to do what we're talking about with with
um with uh raymond he has the
athleticism i think to protect around
the edge
i think that's exactly right he's got
the athleticism he's got the length he's
six foot six the 33 and a half inch arms
and you see that show up but i think for
for me felder you want to see
just a more polish and that's why
they're in the developmental phase there
are times where he could overset and get
beat and there's times where the hand
usage is not perfect so just putting
together that consistency and i think at
six foot six 307 he can carry more mass
on that frame and he'll need to carry
more mass because the power uh from
playing at louisiana from going to the
nfl is going to be significant so for
max mitchell i do think he's a long-term
tackle and probably looking you see
right there rounds three to five so with
raymond you're probably going to look at
an overdraft where max mitchell quietly
can be an under draft that's the kind of
guy you want to maybe use as your jumbo
tackle this year put them in there when
you have six man lines because he can
move people he's got the size but you're
developing him over the long term to
play on the left or the right
oh my listen give him number 85 sneak
him in the game and really make
something go wild
i love it all right let's tap into the
comments before we sign off mcat 93
power user felder's beard gets better
week after week after week i agree with
that all right let's keep it moving i
don't want to go too long here as we get
into the comments tdalt says kyle
hamilton to the jacks at number one a
possibility now felder would you freak
out or would you celebrate
yo i just got done doing i just got done
drawing up my favorite play from kyle
hamilton it's against florida state it's
him going from the left hash to the
right sideline to pick a ball off after
his teammates had two busts on the play
he cleans up the mess the guy is an
eraser i would love to see him go number
one overall i think he's the best player
in this draft you got icky i got kyle
deal all right black mamba fok said and
felder this is literally an alley oop
your way is there an offensive lineman
that has first round talent but could be
a steal in the late second early third
jamari sawyer come on man my boy let's
go we just talked about him i love him
he's the man
the comments rolling rick sauter says
jamari selyer was a team captain on the
best team in the country underrated
exclamation point all right with that
being said
this has been fun i think felder has
gotten everybody on the jamari sawyer
campaign and if that is what draft crash
course is notable for i'll take it all
right we got another loaded show for you
next week we are back every thursday at
1 pm eastern time we will finish off the
third and fourth waves of free agency we
will talk about these pro days we will
preview another division i'm connor
rogers for stadiums michael felder see
you same time same place next week
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you